there was uh some news that uh people
were very pissed that uh xqc was uh
promoting Yakuza series wait was he yeah
he got paid to play the Yakuza series oh
[__] and uh I think people just hate xqc
well okay so there's that there's that
which is fair but people were like
people were getting very upset they're
like why is he getting it when uh this
other streamer who streams all the games
didn't get it and it's like well you
just answered your question he streams
all the games he's going to he's going
to play the whole [__] although I
will say I don't see sqc as a media fan
base being like this looks like a pretty
good game well he he he was like there
was like a a clip making the rounds
where he was playing the game and he
didn't realize it was turnbas combat
yeah and it was like he was it was kind
of a funny I don't know if you can pull
it can you pull it up type an sqc you
wait is it was he playing seven or the
new one the new one what's the new one
um eight or it's like a dragon dragon
like a dragon yeah but it's it's um type
in sqc 8 turn based literally the first
video is why I think xqc was an odd
choice to play yua eight early I mean it
definitely is cuz I think fan base just
isn't yeah like look at this there
articles about it like Dragon fans not
happy about sqc being used to promot
again another game I need to play I
think that actually came out today as of
us recording this I think the the main
issue I think with getting oh this one
yeah look at this one holy okay perfect
guard press o on perfect
guard I mean I have to
double I can't even understand what he
just I'll try
again come on do it he's got to attack
it's his
turn okay then oh my God you know to be
fair I I I think momentarily not
understanding something in a game is
it's [__] it's it happens to everyone
you for a moment you could not realize
that but I think I think a lot of people
get annoyed because it's like I guess
him well he doesn't really do this well
maybe he does I don't I I don't watch
him enough to know but I know that his
audience uh is pretty much anti not
anti- weeb but like generally make fun
of a lot of anime fans people who are
kind of fans of these kind of games so I
think that's why it almost feels like a
slap in the face to a lot of fans of the
series it's that like hey you have these
people who are kind of just toxic online
and hate [__] anyone who likes anime
or like calls it like dumb wee [__] and
it is frustrating to see that almost
being rewarded I think yakaza especially
like the franchise has a very much like
I would say a cult AB the audience is
base um and seeing your beloved series
being promoted on a completely different
kind of like audience and like different
audience members with completely
different values and everything
sometimes you can get protective over
your Series yeah it's it's kind of like
that it's it's kind of a little
Balancing Act you have to do sometimes
where you're like okay I want this thing
I love to get popular but there are some
points there are some points where it
gets like a bit too popular and you're
like okay I wanted it to be popular not
mainstream you know well this this is
how I feel about anime sometimes as well
cuz I'm I'm still like very anti against
like gatekeeping everything like that I
think for example anime getting more
popular more mainstream on the most
Parts uh for like there's there's uh
there it brings more positive things to
the medium as a whole sure but sometimes
I see [__] how Judit kaon fans act
nowadays I see what's happened to my
beloved one peace fan base so wholesome
before and I'm like oh okay I'm I'm very
very happy that these things I'm loving
are getting more popular and more
recognized and then you have like the
negative aspect of it yeah it's it's
getting more popular and more recognized
by people outside of the immedia fan
base which you know on the positive is
it creates new fans for whatever that
thing is but at the same time it also
lets people who were probably never
anticipating to like this thing to
realize that this is a thing yeah and
then getting all pissy about it because
I guess they don't like it or whatever I
feel like anime is just is just now
becoming very very similar to how gaming
fandom is kind of treated where it's
like you know people who are into pubg
have no interaction with a Nintendo fan
of course you know I mean and it's kind
of like that CU it's like all right well
J Jutsu kaison is just pop culture at
this point it is just like one of the
most wellknown
dudee the jutu kaison memes never end
they are just Relentless and I'm I love
it it's great like it's they're funny um
and I think it's kind of like that now
with where a lot of like anime fans are
kind of struggling to kind of like come
to terms the fact that maybe their anime
fandoms are kind of going to be split
like similar lead to how gaming kind of
is yeah I think eventually if it hasn't
already happened well it's already
happened with the big franchises you
know like obviously you know you have
the one piece fans only interacting
usually with just the one piece fand and
like creating these smaller Echo
Chambers I guess of like fan bases which
you know 5 10 years ago when you know
when I was starting off like there was
nothing like that you could be like oh
if you watching this whereas I feel like
the public Zeitgeist of like Jutsu kaon
fans I don't even think they know what a
free Ren is like I love them like but I
also think that like there is this weird
genre of anime fans who think that other
like if they watch like a show like Jud
K and all these kind of very very very
AAA shown entitles they still think that
like something like free ran is weeb
[__] yeah they're like that's [__]
gross weep [__] I'm going to go watch
the jut kais now with the panda uses the
sorcery magic you know I mean it's kind
of bizarre like it's kind of I have seen
the sentiment there are so many anime
fans like that caliber now that just
think that anime is shown and [__] and
everything else is like as you said it's
like strange it's like it's like we are
not the same I've legitimately seen
people who are like meming Jud kaon I'm
like I like who then have no knowledge
of what like a like a Freer or through
Diaries is which is so insane to me
because this five years ago this is just
if you watched any of these shows you
knew about all the other big shows were
happening at the same time absolutely
and I think that's kind of like what's
almost happening in this example is that
like but there there's also multiple
layers to this like I think a lot of
people who are pissed off about X
streamer or ex content creator getting a
sponsorship to X game or watching watch
along xame X gam oh God like this one
it's like okay but not to I'm I'm not
defending him because I don't I don't
care but uh from the perspective of like
how these ad agencies work how these
deals work a lot of the times whoever
publishes uh like a dragon or whatever
will just go to a big Ad Agency and be
like find me a bunch of craters who are
going to play my game here's the budget
just go and find as many yeah and then
there's agents so now the agents are
vying so there probably like multiple
layers yeah it's not like the like a
dragon crators went we want I mean that
does happen though that can happen that
can happen it's very rare though that
that does happen probably happened is
that there was budget flying around
someone some agent managed to convince
some agency and then that's how it ended
up happening for sure I think I think
you know people are mad and I think
that's fair I think it's uh that there
is some justification to being mad that
some content creators get to hey it's
fine the game is out now if you don't
want to watch
XTR but then it's also dumb as [__] cuz
you can also just not watch yeah that's
the thing it's like it's I don't yeah
like again like I I get why people are
angry at this but at the same time it's
like it's not like this kind of content
is being like thrown in your face where
you have it's where it's where it's like
TV and it's unavoidable you know like
you can choose just not to watch this
stream oh also I think the as this
article points out one of the things
people were very annoyed about is that
he had been very negative towards these
types of games in the past right which I
think so it's a little cont it's kind of
insulting yeah to fans who which I think
that that's completely valid yeah I
think it's being annoyed about this in
that context is very annoying especially
if if he has called them trash which
this article is claiming yeah um also I
want to give a quick shout out while
we're on that topic uh of the fact that
my friend is in this game oh yeah Sophie
sop you can you can date Sophie in the
game oh [__] also I think is is K in
this one
too was in the other one yeah she's in
this one too she's a yeah she's a I
think she's in the other there's a
there's a bar game yeah right she's one
of the wasn't this game I thought it was
the previous one dude there's so many y
there is yeah I mean there's like 10 now
isn't there yeah what's what's confusing
is it haven't they released like two or
three different games now in the space
of like a very short period of Time how
do I how I remes of all games the [__]
I'm trying to keep track and I's in one
of them I'm like which one are you in
yeah so kon's in like uh sorry in the
the previous one yeah the seven seven
guy then right yeah and she's also in
this one as like a character in the game
yeah she's like one of the uh is it like
a kakura or something kind of okay okay
okay which is so [__] funny that's so
cool she's like an actual character in
this one right yeah yeah cuz Sophie is
in this one but it's like actually a
picture of
Sophie like it's it's a dating app like
part of the game and one of the girls
you can date on the is literally just a
picture of my friend fcking which is
really funny so good on your s that's so
cool I'm again like dude jrpg eat uh jpg
jrpg fans are eating so well in February
cuz you know we have p3r we have Yu 8 we
got [__] uh gr blue we got fin
Fantasy 7 God when does it end I don't
have time to play all these games bro
you actually do not you you actually
don't but I will find the time to do it
have the time in the entirety of uh4 the
year yeah yeah yeah yeah this is this is
why like man I just it's stressful being
a gaming fan now cuz like everyone's
arguing at each other like you got to
play this you didn't play this game it's
like I only have so many hours in this
anime fans like first
time first time first I'm trying to be a
JPG fan and I'm trying to be a gaming
fan I'm trying to be a film fan I'm
trying to be now you know why jrpg fans
are literally just just JG that's just
why and it's like it feels impossible
now to be multifaceted in media and like
being a totally enjoy multiple media
yeah absolutely and I'm trying my best
to be all all the above yeah because I
go to the movies like every week as well
and I still feel like I'm I'm behind on
movies but you don't want to spread
yourself out too thin right yeah yeah
I'm I am just do what you enjoy that's
that's what ENT the [__] keeping up with
whatever current I had this like
Epiphany where I was like no I think I'm
actually a gaming addict I think I can't
stop gaming like I think I'm genuinely
addicted to gaming it's all I want to do
in my free time that's fair I all I want
to do is listen to music yeah yeah true
that's want to watch anime that's we are
we are same same but different same but
different